hi everyone thank you
we will start with 154 and go to 187
next
ah thank you
congratulations steve futterman from cbs
radio thank you steve i'm not a critic
but i really love the film
can you talk about do you still have
pains and emotions and
uh issues
stemming from what you experienced as a
child growing up there and also i want
to ask you
were you a fan of the film roma because
that seemed to be a film that was also
about another director's childhood
memories growing up
i'll start with the second one i have uh
not seen roma because when i first knew
alfonso quran is a master filmmaker when
i knew that it was a childhood piece i
didn't want to see it because i didn't
want to be either you know influenced or
stopped frankly because he's a master
and so i did not see that
the film is really about the beginnings
of
understanding how to
um deal with the the darkness of those
days which everybody had
their own experience of and as a
nine-year-old
and with a family that were trying to
sort of shield us from it it was to try
and find as much joy and humor quickly
typical of the irish even in the darkest
of uh of situations i think that the uh
the thing that stayed with me
um
was the just the sense of
how how much uh at that time i felt as
though i knew who i was had a very
strong sense of who i was making the
film allowed me to return to that my
sister who's here tonight said this film
has really outed you hasn't it as a as a
kind of working class
belfast boy and uh yes it has because
that's where our dna my brother's here
as well that that's where we come from
and this was a way of
not just acknowledging but embracing
everything about it the dark and the
light
hi
congratulations thank you
oh thank you hi
ken congratulations thanks um
what does this mean to you i mean i've
been following you for more years like
here to say
uh well yeah we have we've grown up
together buzz as simple as that and as a
way you were there in all the places
lots of other people uh weren't in for
you know fringe theaters and the
birmingham rep studio when there's 100
people in and when we had our first
preview of much ado about nothing and uh
and judy dench came round afterwards and
said watching you perform tonight was
like watching a slow-motion car wreck
ken um
i said you think i could do better [ __ ]
yeah i think so i think so um and people
like your good self were kind enough to
point out we were we were having a go
um
you know it means uh it's it's it's very
it's very very very meaningful to me
that as somebody
who
uh was in a small house watching a black
and white television projecting images
of the academy awards to this working
class family in the north of belfast to
come
and
to come and be here at the other end of
that is really it is very meaningful
it's very meaningful and and and and
yeah it's just great my family are here
and that's
a beautiful thing so um
yeah it's it's really lovely
will there be some crack tonight ken yes
there
will be because jamie dawn and the only
thing we're gonna have to really be
careful about apologies in advance if
this happens if jamie dornan sees a
microphone and if a fridge door opens
and a light goes on he's singing
everlasting love it's as simple as that
all right we have 176 and then we'll cut
to our virtual profession
hi roger
i'm good good to see you i'm thrilled
for you congratulations thank you thank
you uh we were back last fall when the
movie premiered we were talking about
how this was the ultimate immigration
movie and you know that a family had to
make a decision
about leaving their home and leaving
their loved ones behind because there
was you know
terror going on around them we didn't
realize back in november that we would
be in that such exact situation now have
you thought about belfast in terms of
the ukraine and the people who've had to
leave
what i've um what i've thought about
rogers the is the um
is the uh what i described as the sort
of miracle of what's happened in the
north of ireland over
uh
the the the lifetime of my generation so
from 30 years of um
dark and tragic trouble through 25 years
of this very hard-earned very fragile
piece which began with what we are
struggling to see at the moment which is
the very very very difficult thing
of trying to begin the process of
understanding
first of all listening to people with
whom you profoundly disagree and finding
a way to listen
understand respect and possibly accept
on the road to progress it's incredibly
easy to say it's unbelievably hard to do
and yet that's where progress is made in
in in the whole of ireland there was a a
generation of people ready to do that
and the example of the last 25 years as
fragile as it remains is still a shining
light in the darkness and it's one that
i would say we want to try and see
shining as quickly as possible in other
situations in the world where
what seems to be the impossible can be
possible and and it is it is
unbelievably difficult and unbelievably
necessary and and um what i see across
my lifetime is an incredible effort made
that has been worth it but please god
situations in other parts of the world
do not cost that amount of time to come
to the same painful understanding that
we need to talk not fight
all right and from our from our virtual
press room we have a question from the
wrath thank you so much thank you thank
you no no we got something much thank
you we have a virtual oppressor oh i'm
so sorry the wrap is coming up sorry
hi kenneth it's joe mcgovern from the
wrap sorry to keep you no worries joe
party um i wanted to ask you know your
it's a beautiful film about a memory you
know um but a half a lifetime ago in
1990
you were first here
as a nominee for directing and acting do
you have any memories from that night
and have you thought about them at all
this evening
man in a in a suit in a pair of dark
glasses came up to me in the wings and
tapped me on the shoulder i turned
around he said hi i'm jack
um i said you don't need to introduce
yourself mr nicholson uh that's what i i
remember i remember being in the loo uh
and uh
sorting myself out as it were and and
and looking to the left and right and
steve martin was here in cuba judding
good gooding jr was there and realizing
that it was um an evening like tonight
has that surreal quality to i've had a
lovely evening sitting next to bradley
cooper and having a lovely chat i've got
a chance to see mr ford coppola who was
a producer on our frankenstein film 25
years ago so the
the camaraderie that that these evenings
produce um in unusual ways is very
special so i remember that um at that
time and i've had versions of it uh
already happening again tonight and
that's been very lovely
congratulations sir thank you very much
i appreciate it and our last question is
from uk press association
hello sir kenneth uh congratulations i'm
mike from the press association thank
you mike
um i was just wondering um how's it been
to see uh young jude hill you know
winning an award enjoying the process
and
of the awards season and you know what
can you say about him and his
performance of you and just how it was
to work with him uh he's a very special
young fellow his parents are here
tonight daryl and shaunine they've done
an amazing job with him and the two
younger
siblings they're a very very nice family
they encourage their kids to be open
funny ask questions jude does all of
that
the single beef i have with him as you
know is that he supports liverpool
football club
and and that meant that directing him
as an actor who had to play a role
supporting tottenham hotspur football
club was a challenge although i did say
to him tonight listen if i can do this
then surely tottenham hotspur can get
fourth place this season and be in
europe next uh he disagreed with me but
i'm backing me
thank you so much thanks everybody thank
you thanks guys
[Applause]
you